The Joe Rogan experience.
Since you started doing these videos on youtube to now,
how much of a difference has it made in the,
the types of people that come to your gym and then the numbers of people that
come in,
um,
that I,
I have Joe Rogan's phone number.
I have Terry crews phone number.
I have doctor Trey's phone number.
Yes.
I you do a lot of pictures of Dr Dre,
man with him a lot.
Dr Dre,
I know you guys look at the news and these might be,
might see,
hey it don't say nothing bad about Dr in front of me.
She is incredible individual and credible.
Dr Dre,
I call them trade now.
Trey is an incredible individual.
His heart is huge,
huge Jew.
I can't tell you how you,
cause it took not too,
but with you.
Yeah.
He's an incredible individual.
Was jacked at one point in time,
right?
Yes.
You,
yes,
he did.
Still looks great.
He told me he,
he's in very good shape right now.
He's um,
a lot of cardio eats really well.
Matter of fact,
uh,
he,
he's got this trail we wants me to,
he challenged me to try out hiking up a hill and I'm not ready for it too,
but Dr Dre is really listening.
I'm gonna make it up there.
Fucking trail.
I might have to roll down,
but I'm going to let you know
he's in great shape,
but he's a great human being.
He's a very good human being.
That's awesome to hear.
I love hearing.
Yeah.
I'll just down to earth.
So he shifted his training from like,
just,
he got really big.
Yeah.
Go.
The comedy store one night and he was like the rock.
Yeah.
You exactly.
You know,
he's,
he's more a,
you know,
health oriented and cardio and he wants to,
uh,
he said his goal was to get down to 200 pounds,
of just lean,
low body fat percentage muscle.
What does he weigh now?
Uh,
two 10.
I think you see it and with me and him saying around the same way,
and I,
my goal is also to get down to 200 pounds.